Dhananjay Trompete für i bestimmt
berüchtigte Biomasse und Shermans
Offensivserienverletzung Ich denke, hey gamez
Trump hat Manhattan getippt, er
hat die Sache mit ihren russischen Prostituierten gestaffelt, die Muschi zu packen
, also denken wir,
er ist ein bisschen vulgär für die ersten
Deutschen. Ich bin eigentlich Bill  Clinton hatte
seinen Schwanz im Weißen Haus gelutscht und
seine Frau stand ihm bei, die Anna
oral gemacht hat, aber das ist nicht die Mühe,
im Weißen Haus zu [ __ ], im Vergleich zum [ __ ]
im russischen Hotel, er war nicht verheiratet,
er war zu der Zeit nicht verheiratet  und es ist in
Ordnung, was er tut, solange er es nicht tut
, das ist der Unterschied. Ich sehe, das ist, was
ein Mann tut  Code, der nicht wie ein
Mann ist, ja, sie drucken unangemessener, mehr als eine
Frau, okay, ich spreche mit einigen der
Frauen aus der deutschen Familie, und sie
sagten, dass die Männer nicht in Verlegenheit gebracht werden
können, ja  Die metrosexuellen Männer in
Deutschland sind peinlich, wer war
mit den russischen Prostituierten
Ich habe davon gehört, dass Sie gehört haben, dass
Donald Trump mit Russland ist. Oh, ich sehe,
Donald Trump braucht keine russischen
Prostituierten  will seine liberalen Medien wie
Sie, sagte ich, erfundene Geschichten über unseren
Präsidenten, okay, ihn beschuldigen,
mit Prostituierten zu schlafen, was völlig
falsch ist, unbegründet und von Leuten
wie Ihnen erfunden, jetzt haben wir darüber, ich komme
aus Deutschland, wer auch immer liberale Medien wie
Sie sind  Diese Leute, die
Leute wie Killer unterstützt haben, und Leute,
die Leute wie Hillary Contin unterstützt haben, und
und und der Rest der liberalen
Esel, die ich bekommen habe, haben mein Land ruiniert
Prozent Strafsteuer, wenn wir sie verkaufen wollen,
und wir hören auf
, unsere Jobs zu stehlen, wenn Sie
Ihre Autos rüberschicken wollen, machen Sie Ihre
Autos dort drüben fein, dann kaufen Sie unsere Autos zurück
k jetzt kaufst du unsere Autos nicht zurück,
ja, warum sollten wir erwarten, dass ich
einen Cadillac oder so etwas fahre
,
es wäre lächerlich, ein 2008er Chevy
Cobalt, und ich habe
hundertzwanzigtausend Meilen damit und das Auto läuft
echt  gut okay okay aber es sieht
scheiße aus nein es ist alles haha ihr habt recht
ja ja die leute im süden ja ihr w
sst was ich sage und wie würdet ihr e
nennen Merkel lässt es zu sie v
rwandeln es in eine Dritte Welt
Nation haben sie Leute kommen ein Propeller
nach Washington die Brunnen in einem
Brunnen, der Bayern heilig ist heilig
- Schwalbe heilig für Österreich Ich
werde grob sein Ich werde ein Mann sein Wasch deinen Arsch und
mein Brunnen irgendetwas von Merkers eine
dümmste breite ich je  Ich habe mein Leben dafür gesehen
, Muslime hereinzubringen, und du hast deine
Vereinigten Staaten ständig geweint. Du kannst versuchen,
uns für unser Essen unsere Vorteile zu bringen - du bist ein
- du und wir sind müde. Ich bin es
leid, für dich zu bezahlen
- Okay, ich sehe, es ist vorbei, okay, die
Geldstrafe ist gut, luc  k viel glück hab ein schönes
leben dir auch du okay tschüss gut ich verstehe ich
denke wir müssen uns trennen es ist vorbei und
trenn dich du versuchst mich ja zu
einem streit mit dir gegen meinen
präsidenten aufzustacheln was niemals passieren wird
weißt du warum weil  8. November
2016, wir haben gewonnen, wir haben gewonnen, wir überprüfen unsere verdammte
Schmuggelware. Ich sehe, ich sagte, danke, das
ist über den
Tribünen  wie [ __ ]
Telefon an saugt hier die Schallwand Mirada
hier ist da Schnaps Fäustling Elston festes
Fleisch Iligan mexikanischer Einwanderer in
der Tat die Wahrheit Mexiko Feb ein Verbrecher Ich hoffe
, ich versuche ein Wrack von Perl der
Schlosser dann von einem ihrer Präsidenten
Bella Cliff Mandas bearbeitet die  Bus ein
Wunder, um die Nuss zu schlagen, gegen die ich auf
meinem Herumlungern hier über nach Russland gekämpft habe,
wie heißt es, es zu beschämen, aber wie heißt
du mit dir, Joe, hallo, Job, und
du bist also ein sehr berühmter Ingwer in Amerika, ich
weiß, ich weiß es nicht  Ich bin fertig, danke
okay, ja, was denkst du über den
Satz einer Aussage von Donald Trump,
dass das Natürliche vielleicht die NATO ist,
vielleicht ist sie in der Zukunft überholt? Die NATO
ist sehr wichtig für unsere kollektive
Sicherheit auf der ganzen Welt, und wir
schätzen alles das  Unsere NATO-
Partner tun ja, und andererseits,
wenn Sie das Mayo verlassen, können Sie, besonders
da Putin ein Freund von Trump ist
, am nächsten Tag an dem riesigen Seilzug teilnehmen
[Musik]
von Ihnen - ich nicht - Ximena Trenholm über
Bhai-Drohnen  Wiederaufnahme von Autos über
Donald Trump über die Karriere der Armee ein
Gemological über Richard Arrington Stimmzettel
über Diamond Turkish
[Applaus]